recently
have been diagnosed with a very rare
neurological disorder it hurts me to
tell you
today
this means
I won't be ready
to restart my tour in Europe in February
Celine Dion emotionally reveals she's
battling a rare incurable disease and
she's postponing her World Tour for the
second time indefinitely as you know
I've always been an open book
and I wasn't ready to say anything
before
but I'm ready now
Celine first pushed back her concert
dates last year first in January then
again in April citing vague health
issues now she shares that this
diagnosis affects her ability to sing
recently
have been diagnosed with a very rare
neurological disorder called the stiff
person syndrome we now know this is
what's been causing all of the spasms
that I've been having unfortunately
these spasms affect
every aspect of my daily life
sometimes causing difficulties
when I walk
and not allowing me to use
my vocal cords
sing the way I'm used to it's very hard
for me not to perform because I love
this thing according to the Mayo Clinic
there are treatments for stiff person
syndrome so hopefully Celine isn't off
the stage for good until that's possible
though Celine says she's getting all the
love and support she needs to recover I
have a great team of doctors working
alongside me to help me get better
and my precious children
who are supporting me and giving me hope
in addition to painful muscle spasms the
disease also causes involuntary
stiffness to the body making performing
next to impossible for now all I know
is singing
it's what I've done all my life
and it's what I love to do the most
I always give a hundred percent when I
do my shows
but my condition is not allowing me to
give you that right now
the thing is that we all go through
tough times we get sick we lose people
we find out things we have to find inner
strength and we are courage we all do
and it's the courage
life imposes things on you you have no
choice you have to deal with them before
celine's Health Battle began she was
already forced to cancel shows due to
the pandemic including a return to Las
Vegas for an all-new residency that
might not ever happen now you can take
so much pressure you can take so much
strength and weight on your shoulders
sometimes it sometimes you cannot
control everything but despite the
struggles and unexpected changes
celine's grateful for one thing the love
of her fans I want to thank you so much
for your encouraging wishes of love
and support
on my social media
this means a lot to me
and I really hope
see you again real soon
[Music]